hello everyone my name is nari Seoul and
I'm a pianist composer with a classical
music background some of you may have
seen this video that I did last year
called funk as digested by a classical
musician and if you did you're probably
well aware of the fact that funk isn't a
genre that I'm very familiar with and
honestly since then I haven't taken this
exploration that much further but
recently I revisited the genre for an
episode of sound field which is a music
channel under PBS Digital Studios
that I'm currently co-hosting with la
Buckner a fantastic drummer so a lot of
people say you should definitely check
it out so in it LA and I wrote a short
song together inspired by James Brown he
first came up with a drum track he then
helped me come up with a bass line over
the phone
and then I added five more lines on top
of it using the keyboard so given my
limitations around writing something
funky since it's not something that
comes naturally to me I had a bit of a
formula in mind to help me out and I
will emphasize the fact that yes perhaps
it's a bit of a scientific approach but
it definitely helped me out so first of
all I focused on sixteenth note
subdivisions for each beat and I looped
short punchy phrases and I made sure to
have enough gaps that were staggered
between the lines just by focusing on
having these gaps that were offset from
line to line certain lines ended up
being very syncopated now to create
these lines I found that assigning
numbers to each subdivision helped me
create syncopated lines so for all of
the beats I was thinking one two three
four one two three four one two three
four one two three four and more
specifically groups of descending
consecutive numbers between each
repetition creates a syncopated feel if
we make the stabs at four three two
it'll sound like this
and three two and three two with a blank
measure in between four three and four
three with the blank measure in between
so I didn't create all of these lines in
this fashion but it really helped me get
started and I think it's a useful
formula to just keep in mind so here's a
breakdown of the different lines I added
on top of LA's drum track
and now here's the final track so I hope
you found that interesting let me know
in the comments what you think and I'll
see you in the next video bye